hi my name is yvonne and today a
therapist is going to match us to our
biggest regrets
hello my name is dr millicent rose i am
a therapist and a professor of clinical
psychology today i have five people and
their stories of their biggest regrets i
actually don't know if i think the
therapist is gonna guess what my biggest
regret was it may be a challenge i tend
to live my life pretty regret free some
stuff is really
and some stuff you can't control she's
gonna enjoy my regret out of everybody
because my regret is unique son i forgot
what it was but we're gonna figure this
out my personal regret i don't think
it's bad but maybe there'll be some
scandalous ones who knows so let's bring
them out
[Music]
so i'm facing away from everybody so
that i can't see their reactions and i'm
going to go ahead and read everybody's
stories my regret is not studying abroad
in college the financial part of it as
well as the credit transfers overwhelmed
me so much that i didn't dive deeper
into it i should have studied abroad the
next regret all through childhood i
wanted to join the navy seals i wanted
to get to do all of the cool stuff like
classified missions but i couldn't swim
i thought i drowned during training
instead i joined the navy during boot
camp one of the seals recruiters came in
and said if anyone wants to join the
seals stand up now and come with me but
i was still worried about not being able
to swim i still regret not standing up
right then and seeing if i could have
done it the next regret i regret trying
so hard to ignore my culture when i was
younger because i went to a
predominantly white american school i
would get made funnel for the foods my
mom would pack for me so i tried to be
like ooh who would eat this plus i was
lowkey embarrassed that i spoke a
different language because people
weren't really nice towards me and the
other non-white kids at my school so i
completely cut out spicy foods next
regret i'm not a person with a lot of
regrets so honestly mine is my first
concert was the black eyed peas and the
pussycat dolls were opening up for them
i didn't buy the iconic pussycat dolls
hoodie don't you wish your girlfriend
was hot like me and i really really
regret it okay and then the last regret
my biggest regret is not taking dance
classes at an early age i feel like it
would have helped me become more
confident earlier it would have added
more swag and i would have been taking
care of my body throughout my childhood
since i wasn't a big sports player all
right so i'm gonna start asking
everybody questions i'm not saying
nothing this time do you like to argue
at all i think i'm a little good at
arguing
[Laughter]
let's talk regrets do you have many i
have regrets tell me another great aside
from this one maybe some decisions i
made when i was younger like
self-confidence stuff and not believing
in myself
tell me how
this regret if self-corrected would
change your worldview i don't think i
would be
living here when did your regret occur
in your life 2010 can i were you in
college in 2010 yes with regards to your
regret do you have any similar regrets a
lot of the other regrets would probably
shape me differently today do you have a
lot of regrets nope why do you think
that is because i'm real what about you
makes you real it's a good question
i don't know because uh i'm as real as
it gets if this regret we're no longer a
regret or let's say it had
self-corrected at the time how would it
change your interaction with your family
i think it would have been
positive i think they would have seen me
as the true person that i am how do you
think your friends would be any
different with you i think my friends we
would have a lot more in common what are
some things about this regret that made
you think about sharing this story i
think that i actually don't have that
many regrets and i don't even want to
say overcompensated for it in my
adulthood but i've really gone like hard
in the other direction you said it would
make a difference to your career yes it
would have expanded my career how so i
want to open so bad but i don't want to
it would have given me more
opportunities outside of the few boxes
that i feel like i'm kind of just always
in if your regret was no longer your
regret would it make a difference to
your career yes this regret occurred
younger in life or more recently younger
in my teens at the time that your regret
was occurring were you aware of it i
don't think so i think i was just so
focused on the present i didn't think of
the future consequences do you travel a
lot i would say i travel more now than
in previous years and would this have
made any difference to your love life
honestly sometimes i think it could have
can you explain why it would help me
communicate better and express better
how would your friends treat you
differently if your regret were not your
regret i think i will have different
types of friends what would be different
about them no no i never went there
would they be more disciplined i
wouldn't know and how do you think your
friends would treat you differently
there might have been some jealousy
maybe because i was more confident in
myself so this regret the idea behind it
is that it would have advanced you yes
how do you think your relationship with
your parents would be any different i
feel like i would have appreciated them
more when i was younger would it change
your family relationships no i don't
think it would have changed my family
relationships okay all right
what would your parents say about this
regret my parents have been supportive
always so whatever makes me happy how
would your family treat you any
differently like god is crazy do your
parents know that this is a regret of
yours it's not that crazy of a big deal
i think they probably would think that i
should not regret it if your parents
today knew that this was a regret of
yours do you think that they still would
have given you the exact same life i
don't think so i'm a tourist so i'm very
stubborn if they really tried to change
me i wouldn't budge
if you woke up this morning and a fairy
had granted your wish and the one wish
that you chose was that your regret was
no longer your regret what's the very
first thing that you notice that tells
you that this regret is no longer a
regret i see
myself loving myself and appreciating
myself i think that i could have
different friendships i don't think it
would have changed
much i feel like i would have achieved
what i wanted thank you for being open
and vulnerable
okay i think i am ready to figure out
which regret belongs to which person
starting with the studying abroad i'm
going to give that one to freddie navy
seals i'm going to give that to
gaddiel ignoring my culture
i'm going to give that to carolina
pussycat dolls hoodie i'm going to give
that to jess and then dancing
regret i'm going to give that to yvonne
[Music]
how's that possible i didn't say nothing
she's a pro you know i was very short
she read my body language and figured it
out i grew up in puerto rico where i
feel like toxic masculinity is a thing
growing up i was always afraid of being
judged but now that i'm more confident
last weekend i took my first salsa class
so watch out
she did amazing i really wish i would
have got that sweatshirt it's literally
the only regret i have in life pretty
much she got me good it's hard growing
up when you're in an area where people
are making fun of the food you eat or
calling you slurs asking you if you're
documented or not just because of your
family's background so i always tried to
suppress that part of me growing up and
seeing all the sacrifices my parents
have made for me has made me
extra extra proud of being who i am yeah
i am really upset that i did not study
abroad in college like i feel like all
of the tools were there i just think
that that would have been a really great
gateway for my love for travel earlier
on in my life how'd you figure it out
the less you say the more you're saying
the more you were saying about being
confident you were trying to redirect me
from something that was clearly more
simplistic by making it more complex
we're always speaking to one another
we're always connecting with one another
this is great thank you guys for sharing
and for opening up thank you
[Music]
you